i want to know all of it when tarantino
another big director
obviously has come forward and said
we've heard these things why does he
look like benjamin franklin now
what the hell happened to quentin
tarantino
he looks like he should be on the back
of a ten dollar bill oh my god
[Laughter]
he looks like he should be flying a kite
with a key on it
he looks like he'll be teaching harry
potter
oh god damn it what happened to walter
frey over here i don't know what
happened what did he
leave well defeat alone so there's
nothing that you've got
you've heard it like you think you know
i'm sorry pause it what is
up with tarantula man what let's
get more pictures of what he looks like
what happened to him
what the [ __ ] age man
oh my god oh but dude he was fine like
three years ago what does he look like
benjamin franklin brendan says he hasn't
been able to use the n-word for a while
that's the source of his use what the
[ __ ] happened to vico the carpathian
over here
he's got a river of slime under his
house oh [ __ ]
we really are gonna have to send a
statue of liberty after him
what is going on oh
god damn it thank you tarantino
oh that was the best lap i've had in a
while
all right sorry it's all good oh [ __ ]
he looks like he looks like he looks
like his best
he could pass for bill murray's mom
oh
oh [ __ ]
oh nick says she's transitioning oh my
god he is
[ __ ] atrocious
what happened
[Laughter]
seriously oh my god
is directing sam jackson really that
hard
he hates working a president
oh he [ __ ] looks terrible oh [ __ ]